dear representatives of the media
i'm glad that i had the opportunity
today to host president of the
commission ursula van der lion here in
helsinki we had good discussion where we
focused on the current security
situation in europe especially russ's
proposals regarding the european
security arrangement and the military
build up around ukraine
i re reaffirmed finland's support for
unity and coordination within the
european union
there can
there can be no compromises on the basic
principles of european security every
country has the right to choose its own
security arrangements
eu stands in support of ukraine and its
sovereignty and territorial
integrity
as we stated at the european council in
december any further military action and
aggression by russia against ukraine
would have massive consequences and
severe costs we need dialogue and
diplomacy and first and foremost russia
needs to de-escalate
security in europe can be strengthened
with a return to forums where arms
control transparency and confident
building measures can be discussed
the organization for security and
cooperation in europe osce remains an
inclusive place for these talks
i want to thank president wonder
for the good discussion that we have
today on the security situation and as a
follow-up of the european council's
earlier discussion on possible use
response to different scenarios and now
ursula the fellow is yours
thank you very much um prime minister
diazana
uh for the very warm welcome and hosting
me here
indeed we had very informative in-depth
discussions about the situation
the crisis russia ukraine
and i'm very glad to be here because you
have
a lot of in-depth knowledge
concerning your neighbor russia
you have the longest border
with russia
and many thanks for
the the
discussions we had here in finland
we have discussed among other topics for
example the military build-up we see
by russia at the border of ukraine but
also in belarus
it is the largest military buildup since
world war ii
we have discussed indeed also the fact
that russia is putting into question
founding principles of the european
security architecture
as laid down for example in the helsinki
helsinki act
one thing
is very clear and i want also to be
clear here about that
finland has
shown as a member state of the european
union always solidarity and it is very
clear
that finland can count on complete
solidarity by the european union
that's what the european union is all
about
while the crisis has been created by
russia
we hope and we do everything possible
that diplomacy and dialogue will succeed
but we are also prepared if russia
chooses any kind of further
military escalation towards ukraine
we are very much aligned with our
partners and friends for example the
united states but also canada united
kingdom
um and in case that there is any further
military aggression against ukraine
there will be
financial and economic sanctions
on our part as a very clear answer we
hope that this is not necessary and we
hope that russia will return back to the
path of peace and of dialogue
thank you and now we have a possibility
for a few
questions finland and sweden said they'd
like a coordinated eu response to the
letter yesterday sent by lavrov do you
confirm that
a response is being coordinated and what
will it say and to prime
yes indeed um we are working on the
coordination of the response
we are united in the european union and
therefore it is clear that the response
will mirror will reflect that unity and
therefore the coordination takes place
right now
as we know the leather was sent to many
eu member states also many nato member
states and we think that it's important
to coordinate the response
there wasn't
that big news in the letter itself but
of course it's important that we discuss
with each other and coordinate when it
pas when it is possible and the finnish
ministry of foreign affairs are looking
now to the latter
and
of course discussion with our partners
yeah
what i want to emphasize is um
as
russia is challenging or putting into
question the european security arc
european security architecture
this is of course also an offense for
all of us all 27 member states and here
in finland i want to be very clear with
all 27 member states we have in the
treaty the article 42.7
which is clear solidarity among us in
any case and in any respect and i just
wanted to emphasize this uh the
challenge that russia is posing to the
european architecture touches all of us
all 27 member states and we will be
solidari we will show solidarity with
each other that's what the european
union is all about
can you repeat repeat the question that
he asked
well of course the only way to find
diplomacy and peaceful
solutions is to have a dialogue and now
it's very important that we will have a
dialogue and trying to find
common ground where we can find
diplomatic answers
nobody wants
this to be
to escalate any further we all want
russia to de-escalate the situation we
want to find peaceful ways out of the
situation
okay thank you so much thanks a lot